on accueille maintenant alain
finkielkraut
bon cela c'est tout le monde enfin je
découvre tout le monde à tous les cas
merci d'être là merci vous vous êtes
agrégé de lettres professeur à l'école
polytechnique et auteur de nombreux
ouvrages d'abord avec pascal bruckner
dans un premier temps comme le nouveau
désordre amoureux en 1977 qui était très
prémonitoire parce que c'était une
tentative finalement de soustraire le
sentiment amoureux à la libération
sexuelle et c'est vrai que l'avenir vous
a donné raison dans une certaine façon
nous n'étions pas des adversaires de les
libéraux de la libération sexuelle mais
nous pensions qu on devait essayer de
réfléchir à l'érotisme et donc à l'amour
en d'autres termes que ceux de la
politique d'autant plus que cette idée
libération sexuelle
en effet elle avait pour conséquence de
minimiser le sentiment amoureux le sexe
était de gauche et le sentiment lui
était répressive se raidit qu est quasi
réactionnelle donc nous avons essayé de
montrer que les choses étaient peut-être
un peu plus compliqué que ça livre
importe ensuite j'ai continué tout seul
et fait le juif imaginaire la défaite de
la pensée
le mes contemporains or là aussi ça a
surpris tout le monde parce que c'est
une espèce d'éloge de peggy oui
venant de vous ça a beaucoup surpris ma
découverte de peggy avait d'abord été
stylistique j'ai pensé que c'était le
plus grand poète de la prose française
et puis ensuite j'ai compris à le lire à
le pratiquer que il était aussi un
immense penseur qu'on ne consultait pas
assez pour deux raisons lui même ayant
été classée à droite parce que 20 ans
après sa mort il avait été
malheureusement récupéré par pétain
alors même qu'il était un poète un vent
invoqué à plus juste titre par les
résistants et puis aussi il s'exprimait
par quinzaine dans les cahiers pour la
quinzaine et donc comme ça avait
l'apparence du journalisme et c'était
lié à un contexte particulier on n'a pas
voulu trop aller voir alors c'est ce que
j'ai cherché à faire pour un ex mao
faire l'éloge de peggy c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque c'était assez surprenant enfin
x-mas août
j'ai été soumis mao trois semaines un
mois donc j'ai quelques circonstances
atténuantes mais j'ai fait pire dans le
gault
séisme oui et je n'ai pas de 2 comment
dire de nostalgie particulière de cette
période de même bien dans même ordre
d'idée vous avez écrit l'ingratitude où
vous parlez finalement du fait que
l'homme contemporain ne se pensent plus
comme un héritier et qu'il est incapable
d'entretenir une relation féconde avec
le passé alors publié aujourd'hui alain
finkielkraut l'imparfait du présent chez
gallimard
votre livre est quatrième sur la liste
du nouvel obs
cette semaine en deux entre cette
semaine il est déjà quatrième serait
demandé à murat rempli par un numéro 4
la première semaine c'est énorme
ben oui mais écoutez vous me l'apprenez
alors il manage ces sous-titrés pièces
brèves
alors c'est pas un journal de l'année
parce que le seuil a fait un journal de
l'année chaque année il demande à des
gens de faire leur journal de l'année ça
mais c'était à la main qu'ils aient vu
d'ailleurs nous en parlait ici là c'est
une notation en fonction d'un certain
manque de date en fait de plus en plus
souvent devant le monde comme il va
je me pose la question qu'est ce qui se
passe je suis jeune mais oui vraiment
qu'est ce qui se passe je me suis dit
peut-être que c'est ça la vraie question
si j'ose dire excusez moi métaphysique
de notre temps
les anciens ont découvert la philosophie
par l'étonnement ils ont posé la
question qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
l'être
qu'est ce que la nature comme ça ils
sont sortis des mythes et tout ça et moi
je pense que la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
et je me suis dit que si je veux
comprendre ce qui est c'est à partir de
cette question
et voilà je me la suis posée pendant un
an voire à votre livre c'est des
prélèvements comme on dit en géologie
des carottes comme on fait pour les
carottes dans le sol comme ça
l'actualité mais sans choisir entre
l'anodin et le l'important disons alors
on va commencer quelque chose de sérieux
c'est le 4 janvier un chapitre qui
s'appelle l'exorbitante injonction alors
là vous vous préciser un truc très très
important qui est rarement dit c'est que
l'objectif des palestiniens au
moyen-orient c'est pas seulement la
récupération des territoires occupés
mais le droit de retour en israël
axa c'est l'objectif qui a été découvert
qui a été découvert après les
négociations de camp david et de tabac
nous ne savons pas nous ne connaissons
pas rigueur
demant la nature des propositions ou des
éventuelles contre propositions qui ont
été faites
ce que nous savons c'est que les
palestiniens ont refusé
l'autorité palestinienne a refusé
l'offre israélienne notamment en
invoquant le droit au retour ce qui est
disons d'un point de vue politique une
injonction
sinon exorbitante du moins tout à fait
inédite et ça je pense que c'est c'est
une
c'est une exigence inacceptable pour les
israéliens et pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que au bout du compte les
équilibres démographiques d'israël
serait rompu et l'israël cesserait
d'être un état juif mais surtout
peut-être plus encore il y a un problème
symbolique
quand les palestiniens réclament le
droit au retour c'est pour dire vous
n'êtes pas légitime
votre état s'est édifiée sur un crime et
c'est une fois que vous aurez explique
ce crime que vous aurez une place parmi
les nations
il y a eu bien sûr des crimes des
catastrophes des fautes mais elles ont
été de part et d'autre et la
reconnaissance
elle doit par ce aile droite elle doit
passer par l'acceptation de la
légitimité de l'un et de l'autre
alors vous rappeler qu'en 47 la jordanie
avait été réservé aux palestiniens en
fait un et que si la dynastie hachémite
qui se remet en paraît d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les palestiniens sont très
majoritaires en jordanie
mais quand je dis tout cela ce n'est pas
pour dire je suis opposé voyais à
l'existence des dvd ça fait 20 ans que
mais non seulement mais justement ça
fait 20 ans que je me je suis un peu
accaparé saisie et comme j'ai des
modalités d'intervention publique jeu
j'ai milité autant que faire se peut
pour la paix pour le compromis pour
l'échangé des territoires pour le
démantèlement des colonies mais je suis
favorable en effet à la coexistence de
deux états et si cette coexistence avait
été voulue par arafat en lorsque lorsque
clinton pressaient les uns et les autres
de trouver un compromis
l'état palestinien existerait
aujourd'hui et c'est cela en six volets
qui une occasion a été manquée et moi je
ne crois pas au processus de paix
un processus est une idée c'est une
fatalité du bien il n'y a pas de
fatalité du bien évidemment donc on est
là devant un abîme peut-être que
l'occasion se reproduira peut-être pas
peut-être que nous allons vers toujours
plus d'horreurs si vous voulez mais si
je dis on va vers toujours plus
d'horreur c'est pas pour justifier s'ils
voulaient la colonisation c'est
simplement pour essayer au moins de
reconnaître la singularité de cet
événement au lieu d'y plaquer comme on
le fait avec le complaisance des schémas
ci voulait très simple il ya les
dominants d'hengoat et qui sont
complètement de dégoûtant et les dominés
de l'autre ils sont complètement
innocent même quand ils commettent des
attentats parce que nous dit on c'est le
désespoir qui les y pousse quel
désespoir peut justifier ce qui s'est
passé à netanya c'est quand même là je
ne crois pas on célèbre la pac
essart et ya 30 morts et des centaines
de blessés
aucun des espoirs n'a jamais fait ça
avant oh et pourtant l'histoire humaine
et une vallée de larmes
donc je que je pense que ceux qui comme
vous d'ailleurs sont attachés à la cause
palestinienne devrait tirer les leçons
du 20e siècle
ça veut dire que vous avez milité pour
une paix juste et immédiate au proche
orient je vous ai vu à la télévision à
la tête de cette manifestation
or dans l'un des dents dans la pétition
pour cette manifestation
il ya cette phrase la politique de
sharon est également criminels vis-à-vis
du peuple israélien qui payent le prix
de l'occupation par la mort de civils
innocents lors d'attentats aveugles car
les hisser les israéliens ne peuvent
espérer vivre dans la paix et la
sécurité en conduisant un peuple au
désespoir autrement dit les crimes du
ramasse sont les crimes de sharon cette
logique élite elle est impardonnable à
comprendre alain que quelqu'un par
exemple comme juliette binoche qui envie
de paix parce que c'est une fille bien
on l'a vu depuis le début de cette
émission c'est que via qui a envie
d'aider les autres ça se voit qu'elles
sont embarqués dans une affaire comme ça
sent vraiment lire toutes les phrases de
la pétition est entouré d'intellectuels
juifs qui est je le tenais une banderole
juifs et arabes pour la faire sur et
contre sharon parce que c'est vrai que
la politique de sharon me semble
il suffit d'ouvrir la télévision pour
voir qu'il ya quelque chose qui n'a pas
progressé
vous avez aussi ouvert la télévision je
pense après ce qui s'est passé
enfin netanya et ça c'est bon enfin peu
importe s'ils voulaient le j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui et il est assez
oppressant que le 21 le xxème siècle n'a
pas eu lieu
le vingtième siècle c'est les paupières
closes le soutien inconditionnel à ce
qu'on appelle des opprimés quoi qu'il
fasse cette logique binaire on sait ce
qu'elle a produit donc je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir plaider pas simplement pour
une politique du coeur mais pour un
soutien les yeux ouverts et rien ne
serait plus plus utile aux palestiniens
aujourd'hui qu'un soutien les yeux
ouverts parce que si on justifie les
crimes qui ont lieu à l'intérieur
d'israël
comment voulez vous après demandé aux
israéliens de démanteler les colonies
parce que disent les colons les colons
enfin ce qu'on appelle les colons les
habitants des implantations des colons
oui ce sont pas des colons qui font suer
le burnous
ce sont des habitants de l'implantation
mais c'est pas pour autant que je suis
pour je suis contre les implantations
mais qu'est ce qui te disent ils disent
vous croyez que les palestiniens ne
veulent que coexister avec avec vous le
long d'une frontière qui est celle de 67
vous vous trompez ils veulent davantage
chaque crime
chaque attentat commis à l'intérieur
d'israël leur donne raison et donc prive
le camp de la paix israélien de
l'énergie dont ils auraient besoin pour
amener au démantèlement
on a le droit d'être intelligent même
quand on mène une politique du coeur
vraiment vous n'avez pas peur de prendre
l'opposé de ce qui se pense généralement
la date du 23 jan 10 h abyssal l
expulsion de la bête et c'est le fameux
débat sur la libération de papon vous
parlez d'arno klarsfeld qui lui
évidemment est contré badinter et pour
et arno klarsfeld a déclaré à la
télévision que finalement si badinter et
pour la libération de papon c'est pour
faire plaisir à jean d'ormesson parce
qu'il veut rentrer à l'académie
française et vous rappeler justement que
badinter a vu son père partir dans l'est
dans les camps je rappelle malgré tout
peu papon a été condamné pour un certain
nombre de séquestration arbitraire mais
il a été acquitté
il a été acquitté de complicité
d'assassinât
or aujourd'hui
si vous voulez cette vigilance qui est
extraordinairement désinvolte négligente
et paresseuse comme papon et le dernier
vivant
elle pense tout simplement que des nazis
sirpa poncet c'est la solution finale
dont on va pas même à 90 en sortir
quelqu'un qui incarne à lui tout seul la
solution finale c'est à dire qu'il ya
carne les crimes pour lesquels il a été
acquitté mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il a
été condamné à dépolitiser là c'est pour
ça qu'il a été condamné en mai 61 oui un
procès n'est pas pédagogique on le voit
bien un procès c'est toujours le procès
d'une personne et quand on fait
symbolisé toute l'horreur de le du
colonialisme de l'occupation et du
nazisme à cette messe est mais personne
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas or qui
a demandé la relaxe de papon au bout
d'un certain temps pour fils mourir dans
son lit badinter
on a parlé de crimes contre l'humanité
mais un peu d'humanité ne ferait pas de
mal et germaine tillon qui a eu cette
phrase extraordinaire nous aussi bien
nous anciens déportés nous avons droit à
la pitié c'est à dire non pas droit à
être pitoyable mes droits à éprouver de
la compassion et qui sont les foutus des
petits jeunes choyé par l'époque
dorloter qui n'ont rien avec eux et si
vous voulez qu'ils revêtent des
vêtements trop grands pour eux et là là
je vois le danger d'un certain
conformisme parce que j'ai pensé aux
hôteliers bordelais qui lorsqu il est
autorisé à comparaître libre par une
décision du président castagnède et à ce
moment là comme un seul homme ils disent
non non non ils rentrent pas dans notre
restaurant il couchera qu'est ce qu'ils
sont ils sont résistants y ce nom ils
sont conformistes et de même qu'en arno
klarsfeld commet dans une émission de
télévision cette agression cet acte de
muflerie il n'est pas du tout repris
parce que on a les yeux rivés sur la
monstruosité de papon c'est ce que le 11
est ce que la dictature de l'opinion
nous désigne donc je n'aime pas si vous
voulez les réflexes grégaire même quand
et même et surtout quand ils prennent la
résistance pour figurer pour prétexte
je parlais d'alternance de textes gravés
de textes légers l'index est très rigolo
c'est nos ancêtres les gauloises sur la
féminisation du 10
cours et vous avez écrit une fable de la
fontaine le corbeau et le renard en la
féminisant j'aurais voulu l'alisier
alors voilà ce que ça donne et c'est une
proposition que je fais est très
sérieusement pour les écoles pour les
écoles maître corbeau et maîtresses
corneille sur un arbre et sur une haute
futaie perché est perché 1 tenait en
leur bec et en leur corne est un fromage
et une tasse de crème fraîche maître
renard et sa compagne par l'odeur
alléché aller chez eux leur tiennent à
peu près ce langage et leur dit ces
paroles et bonjour et bonne journée
monsieur du corbeau et madame de la
corneille que vous êtes jolie que vous
êtes jolie que nous nous semblait beaux
et belles sans mentir si votre ramage et
votre ritournelle se rapporte à votre
plumage est votre livre et vous êtes le
phénix et la phoenix est des hôtes de
ces bois et de ses forêts et j'ajoute ce
poème pourra être étudiée et cette
poésie étudiant e par les garçons et les
filles de l'enseignement primaire et de
l'école communale
l'égalité va enfin régner sur la tête
voilà alors vous parlez du portable dans
le tgv est un truc très bien sur le ca
vous insupporte ça notre présence adore
pourquoi reconnaissance de l'autre
l'autre partout sous toutes ses formes
la femme nommée sexuelle juifs l'arabe
on se reconnaît tout le temps eh ben ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que cette
reconnaissance de l'autre vingt deux
paires très tranquillement avec une
puriste abolition du prochain parce que
c'est ça qui fait très mal
quand les gens ce téléphone sous vos
yeux si vous n'êtes pas là il parle
comme si vous n'étiez pas là
interrogés les chauffeurs de taxi ça
c'est unique moi je le fais je redemande
qu'est ce que ça a changé dans votre vie
il devient intarissable j'en ai un autre
joueur qui me dit mais c'est
insupportable il rentre ou n'est pas là
il n'y même nous demande même pas quelle
course on veut alors le type il me dit
bon écoute et moi j'en ai marre que mon
métier je roule je dis continuez à
parler il va dans une direction qui
n'est pas c'est donc le type s'affole et
10 où vous allez vas y dis moi monsieur
mon métier c'est de rouler mais ils ont
tous les uns et les autres des réflexes
de survie face à des gens qui les gommes
qui les efface et tout ça dans le
meilleur des mondes de la reconnaissance
de l'autre donc c'est c'est amusant mais
je crois que c'est indique actifs du
monde tel qu'il est alors parler de love
story
là c'est assez drôle parce que vous
soulignez l'origine européenne de love
story
c'est au rythme on parle toujours du
démon américain qui va nous apporter une
culture absolument insupportable jusque
là en l'occurrence le story c'est l'un
des pays bas et qu'on appelle 20 des
américains pour inventer ça alors par la
gay pride vous parlez de la techno
parade vous parlez des rave parties est
vous dit en parlant du naufrage de la
transgression qu'aujourd'hui la
transgression est devenu un droit de
l'homme
ah bah oui prenez le droit de
transgresser écouter faire des choses
interdites mais qu'on ait droit de les
faire la fête à faire des rêves étaient
absolument extraordinaire malgré tout
parce que voilà des gens qui créent et
j'apprends beaucoup de mots des zones
d'autonomie temporaire donc formidable
ils se réunissent clandestinement dans
la boue la nuit la plus noire pour
échapper à toutes les récupérations
sordi de ce monde
cette société dont ils ne veulent pas
bon et leurs cousins comédie humaine on
va on va régler ça on va réglementer ça
et puis si vous ne faites pas ce qu'on
vous demande vous allez avoir des ennuis
non non non on devait avoir aucun ennui
c'est à dire et mes fesses et le grand
naufrage à transgresser même la
transgression est un droit de l'homme
alors on revient à des choses un petit
peu plus grave le 11 septembre
d'ailleurs vous ne pouvez écrire là
dessus que le 23 septembre
c'est là que vous dites que
l'intelligence progressiste excuses tous
les terrorismes parce que le crime
originel c'est la domination sakata ce
moment où on a été dominés où on est
dominé ça donne droit à tout et on le
voit bien si vous voulez c'est aussi le
problème israélo-palestinien soit on le
pense comme un affrontement entre deux
légitimités soit on le pense en termes
d'oppresseurs face à naugrim et donc
l'opprimé est innocent même quand il est
coupable tandis que le brasseur il est
coupable
même quand il est innocent toni negri le
pape enfin le l'un des parts de
l'antimondialisation d'un entretien au
monde et il dit
oh écoutez je j'aurais vraiment préféré
j'aurais vraiment préféré que l'avion
qu'il devait tomber sur la maison
blanche tombe sur la maison blanche
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas ça
aurait été vraiment mieux que ces avions
qui sont tombées sur les twin towers
parce que dans les twin towers
il y avait des travailleurs et même des
clandestins mes ennemis ce sont les
hampes les impériaux donc les
clandestins il faut les sauver mais tous
les autres ils peuvent ils peuvent
crever c'est ça serait bien donc vous
rendez compte dans quel univers ce
progressisme nous conduit exactement
l'univers dont toute une partie de
l'europe vient hélas et la mauvaise
qu'est ce qu'on fait les frites
non on essaye de faire beaucoup de
choses en effet je voulais moi je ne
sais pas je sors je crois qu'il y a des
choses à dire et des choses à faire pour
la paix israélo palestinien pour la paix
n'était pas pour cette pétition
mais pour la paix je suis je
dès qu'une ouverture se présente on
essaye de la saisir et quand on choisit
un bourreau après quand on choisit une
cause
on lui apporte encore une fois un
soutien conditionnel
je vous donne un exemple un exemple on
soutient il faut que les palestiniens
est un état et quand on voit quand on
voit à la télévision ça c'est des images
de la télévision
les collaborateurs traîner dans la rue
ou l'inde entre ce qu'ils appelaient
collaborateurs des gens qui ont espionné
pour israël un autre pendu à un pylône
j'en sois la voiture et les gens se
baladent sous les on-dit quoi on dit
c'est la faute de l'oppresseur non c'est
un problème très grave et si vous dites
aux palestiniens c'est affreux
et bien évidemment et se conduire en
autrement et quand ils auront un état
ce sera un état viable pour eux en
revanche si vous ne leur dit rien ça
donnera ce qu'a donné le soutien des
progressistes au fln c'est à dire
l'algérie de maintenant dont tirons les
leçons de l'histoire pour avoir un coeur
intelligent
attendez je reprends ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est dire que quand
quand juliette dit l'algérie faut qu'on
y pense c'est de notre faute ce qui se
passe finalement sonné mal occupé après
l'indépendance etc
de chaque côté il ya déjà des raisons
mais il faut les comprendre ces raisons
il faut essayer en tout cas les
comprendre peut-être se poser les bonnes
questions pour y arriver mais est ce que
le repentir de serveurs de politique
le repentir ça veut dire quoi dire
pardon je crois que quand on a on a on a
tué son père n'a tué sa mère n'a tué ses
enfants je crois que si l'autre côté on
entend par bon bah c'est pas si mal que
ça parce que c'est toujours les mêmes
qui disent pardon d'une certaine façon
même moi j'ai jamais entendu le fln
demandé pardon pour les 150 milliards
qui ont été tuées en 62 et oui oui et je
crois que c'est des deux côtés et de
toutes les façons ça peut pas être que
d'un seul côté je crois que l'on est sur
cette terre c'est on a du mal à vivre
ensemble dessus mais à monde et si on
fait pas d un certain effort même si
c'était difficile et je comprends pas ce
que les juifs ont comme on en quand même
ont quand même vécu l'horreur et c'est
l'horreur aujourd'hui aussi bien pour
les deux ils sont 20 non je donne un bon
soir
parce que je trouve beau répéter que
soit son temps après après la guerre la
seconde guerre mondiale et certains
juifs réagissent comme ça et je trouve
que c'est c'est ce qu'a fait madame yade
merveilleusement c'est que après avoir
été opprimés pendant des années des
années il a su ouvrir
je suis désolé je pense que nous avons
un plan
non mais c'est pas grave de pleurer ça
arrive
ben voilà comment pour ne pas en pleurer